good evening thanks for joining us at 11
i'm denise feltes the family of leslie
palacio is continuing to call for
justice
this comes after jose rangel the father
of the man accused of killing her
pleads guilty and learns his sentence
arc o'mana joining us now live from the
clark county detention center with the
palacio's family message tonight orco
well denise jose rangel is behind bars
here at the clark county detention
center
after pleading guilty last week to two
charges in connection to the death of
leslie palacio
he faces up to two years in prison but
palacio's family says
that's not enough
a family calling for justice 22 year old
leslie palacio
died last august the man accused of
killing her and leaving her body near
the valley of fire
eric rengeli barra is still on the run
and likely in mexico but his father jose
rangel pleaded guilty friday to
destroying evidence and being an
accessory to murder he faces up to two
years in prison
that's not justice at all according to
video evidence first obtained by the
i-team a man who prosecutors identify as
rangel is seen helping his son move
palacio's body
and cover up the crime scene that's why
palacio's family is demanding rangel's
sentence be lengthened as they hold on
to her memory
a friend a sister a successful person
that was trying to achieve her goals
in two years this man will be out on our
streets
this is extremely scary the palacio
family attorney saying a two-year
maximum sentence would only make sense
if rangel was helping police track down
his son
that would be the only justification for
such a light sentence
if eric rangel was in custody right now
loved ones also hoping for rangali
bara's arrest to bring some sense of
closure
we really want him to turn himself in
because that's the only way we want
we could get justice
leslie palacio's family is planning a
protest for this friday starting at 3
30. they're going to start here at ccdc
and then march to the regional justice
center
their goal is to try to convince the
courts to lengthen jose rangel's
sentence
reporting live downtown tonight orca
mana 8 news now